for this fight I've wrestled with
alligators I've tussled with a whale out
on handcuffed lightning and put thunde
in jail I'm so bad I make medicine sick
I can drown the drink of water and kill
a dead tree wait do you see Muhammed Ali
my kids are a lot like their grandpa I'm
in a lot of ways I think the
similarities with me and my grandfather
on the field would be speed at running
back when you have top-end speed had
separates you to the elite category in
the country that's what be Ashur has he
has one play breakaway speed he has
game-changing speed championship game
with Reid and they were tough it was a
state championship game it was tough he
was like a train but we were all on our
feet and it was an exciting moment for
us because we waited all season to see a
breakout ROM I fed and he didn't
disappoint my first 40 time I was
expecting my goal was get like a 4/5 I
ended up running through the end of the
laser and it was a 438 Joshi was one of
the fastest kids in the country he has
the one of the fastest 40-yard dash is
in the United States of America that's
how bad granddaddy was went through a
generation and stayed right on the next
set of boys that came through Nikko is
built like my father he's he's a bit kid
I mean he's a heavyweight for sure when
you see him fight you're like wow this
kid moves really good for a 14 year old
only a few months of training while this
this kidney goes strong for a kid that's
on them in training 14 months he has a
lot of skill sets he's tough and I think
he has a lot of my daddy in that he just
Navin I'll let anyone knock him down I
hope we have a lot of similarities but
you know it's too early to tell he's got
really fast feet when Nikko does the
shuffle it kind of looks like his
grandfather but I won't tell him that
Neko is just like a diamond in the rough
is a lot of dirt around it it needs to
be polished needs to be chipped away the
road to travel is a long long road
trainings not supposed to be fun really
it's just supposed to be getting you
prepared for your next step and in my
case it would be going to the amateurs
there's a lot of pressure with that last
name you know being an ollie it's a big
deal I don't want people to think you
know oh he's getting all this you know
cause of his name and stuff so it just
makes me want to prove myself that I'm
actually good at the sport rather than
who I'm related to I think they have
more pressure because they're in sports
I think yeah Jon Nico especially Nico
has extra pressure because you're
following on an iconic legend there's
only one Muhammad Ali and I don't want
to even try to replicate it because he
did everything wrong really he put his
hands down and didn't get hit and he sat
on the ropes and didn't get hit and if I
did that I would get hit
the one thing I'm spending the most time
with Nikko is just trying to just
diffuse everything he's got a name he's
got a family thing going on and it's
just we're working out and I really try
to minimize all of it
because I know his first fight is gonna
gain a lot of attention it's sort of a
good thing and it's sort of a bad thing
it's bad in the way that when I start
boxing amateur leap they're gonna use
their love me or they're gonna hate me
they're gonna want to take my head off
or something they're gonna be like I was
the one who knocked out Muhammad Ali's
grandson
I can't even imagine the amount of
pressure of Miko and Biaggio is going to
face
I feel like boxing is in my type because
I like a team sport I like have the
links to the chain build up a team it's
hard for me to take a shot for someone
else's mistake and I just want to I want
to pay for my own mistakes and I want to
do good and get credit for what I do I
just like more independent sports Nico's
passion for boxing is almost scary
because I said I want him to be that
passionate I don't want him to like
boxing there's only a handful of people
in my family that actually wanted me to
box because you know they were afraid
that Parkinson's disease would would be
cause maybe from boxing
and it's it's a genetic disease so it
could it could be passed down to me if I
continue to box and get hit and stuff
like that and I would really hate for
that to happen the work I do is in
neurodegenerative disorders that's what
I do um I wrote a book on Parkinson's
disease I'm a little nervous about the
high impact sports football in boxing a
like my parents they want me and my
brother both to just be healthy and they
don't want us getting our heads knocked
around and you know I understand that
but I just got to do what I got to do my
favorite Muhammad Ali quote would be to
suffer now and live the rest of your
life as a champion Biagio has got that
in him that desire to be great in him
that's the biggest thing he contends
with I don't even know that the shadow
of the grandfather plays on him as much
as his own desire to be great I'd like
to get Nikko some junior Olympic boxing
matches within the next three months or
so stop getting them in there there's no
telling how far I can go yet I'm fresh
out of the egg and boxing and I need to
see where I go from there I said to him
one day I said what do you want to do
with this you know we working out we
exercise him what do you want to do with
this Nikko and he said I want to be
world champion I want to be heavyweight
champion and that's when I said to him
you know that takes an awful lot it's a
hell of a dream but I'll tell you what
dreams can happen dreams do come true
you
you